[Music]
well welcome back to another episode of
the addie hour it's it's hard for me to
believe this is actually episode 31 um
so we've had a lot of great
conversations over this last year and i
have so many different guests from so
many different walks of life um it's
been great to see how you all have
engaged in these conversations as well
from things that people have been saying
on social media from emails um we're
gonna have more opportunities for some
of that engagement coming up so
definitely stay tuned uh and and stay um
stay informed because we look forward to
having those engagements with you
so today i'm very honored to i was
saying beforehand this is this is a day
one uh thought partner in a lot of ways
who's joining the podcast today just
with some of the initial events that we
did around town hall conversations on
different college campuses and so i'm
grateful to be able to welcome today's
expert to be able to join us and today
we have dr myra mathis joining us for
the topic of conversation is going to be
addressing addiction and thinking about
faith psychiatry and neuroscience
perspectives so myra thank you so much
for being here on the addie hour you
have ownership of this if you want i
feel like you have a you have invested
into this podcast even if you didn't
know it from from early on so appreciate
you being here well thank you so much
for having me it's so wonderful to be
here and to see where the podcast has
come from those initial conversations as
you were planning and preparing episode
31 that's just that's phenomenal thanks
so much i definitely appreciate that
i know some of our listeners are already
familiar with you because you served as
a moderator for our new york event god
mental health and wellness we also
co-hosted the grand rounds at yale where
we had the cray come and speak to our
community here but of course this
audience has grown as well and there are
many who aren't familiar with you so i'm
going to go ahead and give you a brief
introduction to introduce you to them
so dr meyer mathis is a faculty member
at the university of rochester medical
center she actually trained in general
and adult general adult and addiction
psychiatry here at yale
she currently provides substance use and
mental health services at strong
recovery which is an outpatient dual
diagnosis clinic
dr mathis also serves as co-chair for
the opioid response network black
communities work group where she helps
promote effective utilization and
dissemination of culturally responsive
technical assistance for black
communities disproportionately affected
by the overdose crisis
as a clinical educator dr mathis also
facilitates educational experiences for
medical students for residents and for
fellows in addiction psychiatry and she
pursues her academic interest in
advancing health equity and racial
justice through scholarship and the
development of collaborative community
partnerships so someone as you can hear
who's deeply invested in education
deeply invested in the clinic and deeply
invested in the community and so we're
honored to have dr mathis here with us
today
thanks so much for that introduction
of course
great to be here
well i'm excited to to be able to jump
straight into the conversation i'm going
to try and hold back and not reminisce
too much on some of the events that
we've put together in the past because
there's always
just been um
i've just been a generous response from
people who have been engaged in those
conversations we'll be appreciative for
the ways that you helped shape some of
those conversations as well
but as i mentioned to you and as my
listeners know we always start out just
doing a general check-in so obviously
there's a lot that continues to happen
in our country i just wanted to start
and have you share with our listeners
how you're doing um at this point in
time especially with all the roles that
you have well thank you so much for the
question um
yeah it's
it's a heavy time um in our country in
various parts of the country
really all over the world there are so
many
challenging uh tragic
um horrific incidences of
mass violence and and
it's just a really heavy time and now
that i'm based in rochester new york
it's uh upstate just 60 minutes away
from buffalo
so um
those things are still
present with me as it is with so many of
us and trying to figure out how to
um
not just be overwhelmed by the grief and
the trauma but to
be engaged in some form of action to try
and shift that so that it doesn't feel
as hopeless and so that we don't feel as
powerless
um
so that's that's where i'm at
well i definitely appreciate that level
of honesty and you know as we've been
talking to just that tension of trying
to
navigate as a society too so that we're
not just overwhelmed all the time
but again of course we don't want to
ignore what's happening but we don't
want to be stuck in it as well so i
appreciate you just highlighting that
and
letting us know how you're navigating
that as well
as a follow-up and i guess somewhat
related to what is your what does your
day-to-day cadence look like in your
position for those who might not be as
familiar with what an addiction
psychiatrist does for instance um
especially with everything else that's
going on already too
so it really varies from day to day but
i'll give sort of um the mix of
activities so i'm i'm seeing patients um
and i can see patients who have a
primary substance use disorder so um
some days i'm getting folks inducted on
medications to treat their opioid use
disorder or to help with cravings for
cocaine use or nicotine use things like
that
and i may go from that appointment to
seeing someone who has both a
combination of substance use and mental
health concerns and talking to them
about medications to address one or both
of those things
i'm also working with residents who may
be in the clinic rotating and they may
see a patient and then we discuss the
case and i give them some teaching
points um some days i'm doing a lecture
some days i am
in administrative meetings actually
that's probably every day
that i'm in some sort of administrative
meeting both related to clinical work
but also related to some of the the
health equity work that's really um a
passion for me and at the core of a lot
of what i do so
um
the day varies but uh thinking about
the patient
and the systems that are treating our
patients that's sort of at the core what
i do
i appreciate you sharing that as well i
think that gives people you know
snapshot and a sense of some of those
things i think there's a lot of things
there that we can unpack as well in
terms of how people enter into the
spaces where you are and how you're also
entering in and trying to meet them
where they are but before we go there i
was wondering if you'd actually just
take people through your path as well
how did you get to this place of going
into addiction psychiatry is it
something that you have an interest in
early on is it something that came up a
little bit later down the road like what
did that path look like for you
yeah so it's really interesting actually
i um
it wasn't something that i thought i
would do from the beginning and even my
journey to psychiatry was somewhat
circuitous when i went to medical school
i didn't think that i'd become a
psychiatrist
but my
rotation in third year on psychiatry
clerkship really opened my eyes to um
the difference that could be made
and also just the importance of um
from a faith perspective was considered
the ministry of presence what it means
to actually just sit with people and be
present with them when they're facing
challenges
and psychiatry
an opportunity
to sit with folks when they're facing
various kinds of difficulties
and to work collaboratively with them on
how to move forward and take the next
step
so
that's how i got hooked in psychiatry
and then a similar thing happened to me
in residency while i was going through
various rotations and i did my addiction
psychiatry rotation and um i realized
that we can actually help
that
treatments work for addiction and that
there is something that can be done and
when i'm meeting with someone again
feeling
overwhelmed by the symptoms of their
substance use disorder overwhelmed by
the consequences of their substance use
that
that we can work collaboratively to
figure out what that next step will be
for them and
seeing that there was something that
could be done and that there was hope
within the field of addiction that
really hooked me and
that's how i continued on this journey
wow that's really powerful and inspiring
now just to hear about what what pulled
you in and i sense that that continues
to motivate you as you go forward too
but even as you just talked about you
know the ministry of presence and all
that i mean it's it's really powerful
and i can imagine that people
are grateful for that approach as well
um you know as you were talking about
just the treatments that are there and
these things actually work i'm also
curious if people come into your office
or into treatment with that mindset or
if that's something that you feel like
you have to instill or if it's a mixture
um and we'll get into you know some of
the uh stigmas and things like that as
well but as you were talking that was
just one question that came to mind
yeah it is a mixture and it all depends
on where someone is in in their recovery
journey
um so i have patients who are coming in
for the first time and don't really know
what to expect
and you know we
let them know what the options are and
let them know what the evidence shows in
terms of some of the treatments that we
have to offer and how effective they are
and
you know what they can expect out of the
process
and then i have other patients who
have been in various treatment programs
whether it's inpatient or outpatient and
they've done it so many times
um
and they just feel like
i've tried everything and i'm not sure
where to go from here
um and that's a tough spot to be in but
i think it's also important as a
clinician
to hold that space of hope even when the
patient is feeling like they're in a
place that's hopeless
and so i'll sit with them and in a
similar way i'll say well let's go
through the options
because there may be a combination of
things that you haven't quite tried yet
or you're in a different place in your
life than you were in in the past and so
something might work now that didn't
work before
so really it exists along the spectrum
some folks are
well aware of the options and feel like
you know
i'm not sure what can really happen here
and other folks are coming in sort of
brand new trying to figure out how this
journey will look for them so just
meeting people where they are
and trying to maintain that space of
hope um while they have options to
pursue their next steps
that's great i mean i appreciate hearing
that you're meeting people where they
are and it sounds like you're also
having a dialogue so it's not you just
disseminating information saying this is
what has to happen but really hearing as
you said meet them where they are and
hearing what they're bringing into the
conversation as well yeah that's helpful
on a lot of fronts
absolutely there's there's no way that
it can only be a one-sided conversation
i mean if you just think about any any
doctor's appointment that you attend if
the doctor is the only person doing the
talking they they're they may suggest
things that actually just don't fit and
work for your lifestyle the best medical
advice that i've gotten myself is when
my doctor is actually listening to me
and hearing what my life is like and
then adjusting the treatment
recommendations based on things that
might actually work for me and i feel
like that's the only way that we can
really be successful
in any medical treatment but especially
in this in the space of mental health
and substance use yeah that's so
important it actually reminds me of you
know some of the comments that came up
in the town hall that we had near new
york city i remember vicki sigworth from
the national alliance on mental illness
in new haven just talking about you know
when people and this was much broader
than addiction psychiatry but then when
people are going in to see
anyone around mental health whether the
practitioners are saying just telling
them information or saying tell me your
story
it sounds like you're in that same
mindset of what what is your story
what have you been through what have you
walked through where are you right now
what have you tried whether you're not
trying then trying to find that balance
to have that two-way conversation which
i think is so so important on so many
fronts um and even as we think you know
even outside or not outside but in
addition to the psychiatry as i think
about as a neuroscientist i've had some
of those same experiences as well even
if i'm talking about for instance in
neuroscience of addiction an event that
i did a public library that was really a
two-way conversation it wasn't just me
there disseminating all the information
it was helpful to hear from people what
their experiences were to see how that
impacted how they interpreted what i was
saying and to also have them share while
i was on this medication that made me
feel this way whether you're what you're
saying about what happens in the brain
is also helpful so just kind of a back
and forth dialogue where we are both
able to learn from each other
and i think everyone came away from that
with a much better understanding even
though it wasn't a clinical setting per
se
but i feel like that's just important
for us to do as a society so that we can
have better understanding from both
sides or all sides and really have a way
to move forward so it's really
encouraging to hear
i love that you did that when it came to
neuroscience like that is really that's
really exciting uh because so often
conversations related to whether it's
mental health or substance use um
it's
even the neuroscience of it stays in a
clinical space
um there isn't a lot of engagement in
public spaces with the science of
addiction or the science of mental
health concerns and um so so that's
really impactful and it sounds like it
it was also empowering for individuals
who were there to have the science sort
of presented to them in a way that's
like digestible and
they can really appreciate and
understand yeah definitely and it was a
really important reminder for me as well
i mean some i think there were
perspectives that were changed from
people who came in and also for me as
well some people came in saying i don't
see the addiction as an illness
because i did this to myself yeah which
i always say of course that's true at
some level because you have to use
beforehand initially if something is
going to transition to that point but i
think at the same time they also came
away saying okay now i have a better
understanding of what my use has done or
is doing to my brain
in terms of long term and i also have a
better understanding that that's not the
end of the story
there are different ways that yes the
brain has changed because of the
exposure and use but it can still
continue to change our brain changes for
all sorts of reasons and experiences
that we go through and there are ways
they can continue to change and they can
move through it so i think for me it was
helpful to see how they also process the
information and then incorporate it into
their understanding and i would say for
me bringing that back into the lab
setting even for us who are in the lab i
think it also gives people perspective
on why we do what we do what impact it
has and not just thinking about within
the specific lab environment as well so
i think all the way around those things
are so important from from a teaching
perspective and obviously we're trying
to make sure that we don't keep these
conversations stuck
in certain
silos in certain venues in a lot of ways
that's why i'm so grateful
for the way that your work
touches all of these different
components even as you talked about the
beginning the administrative roles the
teaching roles the work in the clinic
you're doing a lot in the community i
think that's so important and so
powerful
thank you i appreciate that
it's it's important that it sits uh
hopefully that feels gratifying because
i know that when we're in the work in
the moment it doesn't always feel that
way at least for maybe maybe more so for
you in the clinic but
you know that's really interesting so i
um
hearing you talk about how you can bring
those experiences with the community
back to the lab
that um
that's really moving for me because i do
think about um as you said these silos
and um
that research can feel so disconnected
from sort of like
the day-to-day sort of realities whether
it's of someone's life and their
addiction and even um
the challenges between what happens in a
research world and what's happening in a
clinical setting
and that the communication across all of
those settings is really really
important to keep
keep patient experiences at the center
um that our research is informed by
those experiences so that it can help us
do better clinical work it's like we we
need the research to inform what we're
doing in the clinic so we can be more
effective
but again if we're not really listening
in terms of what the patient experiences
we may be focusing on a really
interesting and novel sort of research
finding but how do we bring that back to
the person who's like
struggling and still trying to figure
out their path and their way forward so
um that that really um excites me to see
that those conversations and that
engagement is happening across various
sectors
yeah i am
i
am reminded of
in that same way
um
even in sort of my day-to-day work it's
not something that i think about
explicitly but in this conversation it's
reminding me that often
the challenges that i'm trying to work
out in an administrative setting have to
do with barriers that i've seen my
patients face
like that i'm that i'm realizing this is
a wall we keep running into and so how
can we adjust our systems and our
practices so that my patients aren't
always running into this wall yeah
that's such an important perspective i
imagine you might have to remind
yourself of that
a few times as you go through just yeah
because it's easy
so easy to lose sight of that yeah i
think as much as we can remember that
across the board and different things
that we're doing um is important and i
would say you know in some ways it's
still surprising to me and i guess it
shouldn't be but sometimes it surprises
me the impact that things can have so i
definitely agree as we're moving things
need to move things on a system level
but even individually sometimes um so i
remember one talk i did when i was just
talking about again the basic science in
the lab and talking about some
experiments that we're trying to you
know do in rats or mice to try and model
addiction or depression which obviously
you can't do all that easily but trying
to think about this back and forth
translation and having feedback from
people who said as you described what
was happening in a clinical situation
how you tried to model that and how you
tried to go back and forth it said even
that gave them insight into what they
had seen their loved ones navigate
mm-hmm
disorders to me that was surprising
because i don't often think about it in
that sense even though we're trying to
model i don't think about what are
people actually going to get from
thinking about
what we're saying about what happens in
the brain and how an animal might behave
that might give them insight and
understanding to how their loved one
might be acting in a certain way so that
to me was really powerful and i don't
think that's a common
experience that we think about if we're
talking about the science that it can
actually have a direct application to
how somebody thinks about
how someone they know is responding and
how they'll also approach that person
yes having that understanding about okay
well this might be happening this set of
uh
pathways may be active in their brain
this way and that may be causing them to
react in this way and maybe i should
enter into that in a different way so to
me that was just
that was just shocking because i didn't
see it even though you would hope that i
would think about that but
so what you're describing and um what
excites me about that is really how um
some and there are lots of folks in the
field of addiction who have been
really trying to push this message in
terms of the science of addiction
helping us to combat stigma
because
the behaviors of a person with a
substance use disorder
are so hard to understand
right so you're just like you're talking
about a few discussing this moment with
a family member who
start to have an understanding why their
their loved one
might respond in a certain way
and
that in and of itself because the
behaviors are hard to understand then
they are stigmatized
and it's like the science of addiction
can help us understand like what is
actually driving some of those behaviors
that we that other people find hard to
understand when we don't understand
something we make it in other in
whatever way that is it's different from
us it doesn't make sense and so we
distance ourselves from it
but bringing that understanding in a
very practical way i think that helps um
it really does help us to come back the
stigma and helps us to
help families and individuals understand
why
certain changes are happening in the way
someone engages with their world
yeah
yeah that's really encouraging and that
now it's my turn because i have to
remind myself of that too
you know just in the day-to-day because
it's so easy to decide that
yeah to follow up on that i mean since
you brought i mean appropriately this
this aspect of stigma and how the
science can inform that how do you
approach that in your day-to-day even
though there's a range of things that
encompass your day-to-day but how have
you tried to navigate and help people
move past the stigma so they can get to
the place where they are coming to get
the treatments that you have mentioned
are effective
yeah
it's really interesting so i find that
stigma
it acts on so many levels
especially when it comes to substance
use
um there is um
there is an internalized stigma where um
you
individuals wonder what whether or not
they are worthy
because they've been treated in a way
that makes them feel as though they're
not
and that can happen at various stages of
someone's recovery
you know someone who's
been abstinent from substances for a
period of time um but they're still
working on rebuilding relationships that
have been broken
and
for them to really know that they're
worthy of healthy relationships
to overcome an internalized stigma about
what kind of life they
are worthy of having
and again it happens along the spectrum
of recovery
where i find stigma to be most
challenging though is um
in
the systems that are meant to serve our
patients
and that is the part that is really um
that's the part that could be really
discouraging
um it's it's definitely discouraging for
patients when they try to access help
and then when they finally
sort of
when they finally
make that decision and have the courage
to make a choice towards treatment
and they're met by
stigmatizing
behaviors and language from care
providers
that's the thing that
really makes my job more difficult
and so i'm very careful in my language
i model language even in the health
record as i talk about patients and as i
describe their behaviors
um
i
never use i use person first language i
um
prefer things terms like abstinence
rather than sort of a clean or dirty
right um so
these are some of the practical things
that i implement in my daily
work
to combat that stigma and that i'm
humanizing someone when i'm talking
about them even even in my even in my
clinical documentation
that i want to make sure we see
this individual as a whole person and
not only as
someone with an addiction
um
so that's
that's where i find myself that's the
space i find myself in most often um
modeling it
trying to do some education with my my
uh colleagues and peers and co-workers
some of the
some of the clinical research on on
stigma demonstrates that
using stigmatizing language directly
correlates to choosing more more
punitive sort of responses to patients
so it informs the way we decide to treat
someone
if we use stigmatizing language
and if we read stigmatizing language in
the chart it informs how we view that
person and what we think they're worthy
of in terms of their treatment
so it really is important
how we talk about addiction how we talk
amongst ourselves as clinical providers
and then what that looks like in a
patient-facing way yeah oh that's huge
and so important where do you think and
this might be speculative where do you
think that comes from in terms of within
those settings the fact that
stigmatizing language is still there and
maybe another question on top that
do you think it's intentional
or is it
even or is it something that's not even
realized just the way that things have
been done
that's interesting um
so
this is this would be speculative but my
my thought is that
we have
systems and structures that actually
stigmatize our patients that that some
of the stigma is written into policies
in terms of the ways that we treat
individuals with substance use disorder
um
the
the history of equating substance use
with criminality in such a deep deep way
um and
that
those policies and that
those media portrayals going back
decades
really inform how people think about
someone with an addiction
and they do see them as sort of um
in the worst
in worst case scenarios as sort of a
crazed
criminal
and
those uh public sort of media portrayals
whether you're in a clinical setting or
not that's just in the water in society
and
um
it
takes change in multiple levels and
sectors to really shift
how we're perceiving patients and
individuals with a substance use
disorder in society overall
and then also what that looks like in
medical settings
there's
thought of as the sort of difficult
patient
and
because it may take more time to
understand their behavior right
then
again even in a medical setting
walls are put up to say
that's the challenging patient that's
the difficult patient and
conscious or unconscious we have these
responses yeah and then like you
mentioned it has an impact on how things
are perceived when it's written into the
chart and then to add on top of that
when you think about our black and brown
communities that's a whole nother level
so i mean what what have you seen
around that either from your
observations or i mean from what's been
some research as well like how does that
how do those do two things intersect in
terms of the language that's used and
people's
background yeah that's a great great
question um so uh black patients
regardless of their diagnosis are more
likely to be labeled aggressive
right in in medical documentation
um and so uh when you
add in the components of substance use
disorder right if someone is withdrawing
from a substance right and that impacts
their their behavior they're physically
uncomfortable to the point that they
feel like
for some substances the withdrawal feels
like you're dying like you really you
just you're in such discomfort that um
it is overwhelming right and so if
someone
uh if a black male comes into a medical
setting
in that level of discomfort
and he's yelling and saying i need help
right now right that that that that's
not perceived as
oh this is someone
who
it doesn't engender these sort of uh
caregiving responses
from the clinical staff right and
we know what and how
implicit bias works
another aspect of this is how burnt out
individuals in the healthcare system are
which means they're more likely to
respond based on bias so in the middle
of an overdose crisis that's
disproportionately affecting black
communities and communities of color
right we need caregiving spaces to be
welcoming and affirming and safe
for people to engage
truly so that we can be saving lives
[Music]
but black individuals coming into
seeking care are less likely to receive
medications for opioid use disorder um
even in emergency room settings which is
a critical point of intervention when
we're thinking about overdose crisis
so so the data is showing that the
clinical behavior towards communities of
color is different
in it when it comes to addiction
treatment um and
i think it's the interplay of stigma
racism and racial bias
those things in combination with one
another
um
really contribute to the difference in
care that is
offered or not offered yeah
yeah i mean even as i'm listening to you
talking i'm just thinking about all the
impacts that has on the outcomes yes and
i'm thinking i mean it's giving me a
level of empathy on both sides both for
the
person who is walking through that if
they feel like they're dying then also
for those who may not be responding that
to that in the appropriate manner
because of biases or because of being
burnt out and again i'm thinking about
the neuroscience of that and if both
both situations both individuals are at
a high level of stress how that just
can amplify things but then it has such
tremendous
impacts on outcomes not even thinking as
you talked about in terms of overdose i
mean that's a life or death
ultimately situation potentially um so
again i mean just everything you brought
up just giving me
time to pause and just realize how
important all these different components
are at all these different levels and as
you mentioned before it's something that
has to happen
um on a systems level as well so lots to
do but again i'm grateful for the ways
that you're doing that in some ways away
i think even this conversation we're
having is giving us some insights about
different
areas where many of us can maybe
intervene and be proactive and make sure
that we have a better understanding
of those types of things as well but
again it makes me just grateful for
for the work that you do and for the
fact that you continue to do it as well
because i think it's a mixture there's a
lot of hope there but it could also be
easy
to
have some aspect of despair or is this
actually making
a bigger impact and a bigger difference
which i imagine can come into play as
well
um
but i appreciate that
i was just going to say when it comes to
maintaining hope
um
that also comes with my interactions
with my patients
that's how i maintain hope
when when i see
when we have a moment and we're
recognizing that things are working
and we get to celebrate that together
like that is just that's powerful i had
one of those moments this week and i was
just
uh i'm going to i want to share
and i'm just thinking about the best way
to do that um
and so uh but
um this is a particular patient that has
alcohol use disorder and really really
struggling with alcohol use disorder
severe withdrawal severe medical
complications of alcohol use including
pancreatitis requiring stays in the icu
for the withdrawal just
really really um
very very sick
um
and
we tried various medications to help in
maintaining abstinence but that wasn't
really working
and so
we started just talking through a plan
of well what does it look like to cut
down on your alcohol use
on your own
with all of the engagement and various
treatment resources coming to groups
doing doing a little bit of aa during
just multiple different supports
um
and
for the first time a patient came into
my office after not having had alcohol
for a couple of days and there were no
physical signs of withdrawal like blood
pressure was normal and and all of this
came from
sort of really harm reduction principles
and slowly thinking about how this
person wanted to decrease their alcohol
use because medications just hadn't been
working and it was the first time that
their body like actually was showing
a physical response
that the plan was working so i just like
look this is it in black and white
we're making progress this is good so um
made my week
that's great i mean definitely the hope
there but definitely i'm sensing you
know the joy too yeah it comes from
seeing that shift
yes
yeah and celebrating it and celebrating
you have to and and there are some who
might look at that from the outside and
they're thinking well but the person's
not fully accident from alcohol right
and so so
what does that mean
um and here i am saying no we take every
win
and we celebrate every win
and that is
worth celebrating yeah fully agreed i
appreciate you sharing that as well the
end of that joy just just
is so evident in a lot of ways and i
think yeah that's that's what sustains
me those moments where
um
i can celebrate with my patient
in the progress that they're making yeah
yeah
wow that's so impactful
and so many aspects of you you know
being a conduit to give hope in a lot of
ways um and you know just as to to kind
of wrap in the faith component as well
knowing that you're a person of faith
how does all of that you know as we talk
about this topic of hope how does all
that intersect with all maybe not all
maybe that's too many but many of these
things it does intersect with all but i
don't know if you have time to go into
all that but
with many of the topics that we've been
talking about um and then you're just
your perspective
in your day-to-day
yeah
um
you know it
does come back to that idea of the
ministry of presence i think that that
um
um
being present with someone can't be it's
you can't undersell that the importance
of that
um
and like
and to really really
sit with someone and to let them know
that they've been heard
um and
the medical system
can keep you busy seeing patients at a
really rapid pace and
um you know i do my best to minimize
that in my schedule to as much as i can
and i'm grateful to work in a in a space
that allows me a measure of flexibility
to be able to do that
because i recognize that that doesn't
happen everywhere and the need is so
great that there are so many people that
need to be seen
and it can leave you
just running from one room to the next
to the next to the next
so i do my best to do a little bit of a
self-check-in before i go in the room
with the patient
to
be sure that i can actually be present
with them
and not just kind of go through a
symptom checklist but to really really
actually be able to hear them
um and
i know that that really does come from
what i've
experienced in my walk with god
i'm
the importance of knowing
um
that he never leaves and never forsakes
you like that he is present with you
that that um
i know how
radically that transforms my
daily outlook
to know that he is with me
and
um
i just feel if there is a way
um and certainly i'm i'm not talking
about god in my clinical encounters
unless a patient brings that up to me
that that's a important part of their
recovery and for many patients it is
for some patients it's not at all i have
a patient who happened to find me on
twitter and told me how he realized that
i was a spiritual person and he's not
really the man
and we had
we had a you know
about that but but it was um
uh so just as an example of the ways in
which you know i'm i'm mindful of those
boundaries um
and at the same time i do feel
that it is
um
an extension
of god's grace
to be present with someone else
and to just and to sit and hear
and to hear without judgment and to let
someone know that they've been
understood
and
um i don't i'm not able to do that
every day and every visit because it's
busy and that's hard um but i try to
take a moment to be mindful if i'm
having a stressful day and i know it's
going to be a little harder than usual
to just be present with someone then i'm
taking a few moments before i walk in
that room
i am breathing i am centering myself i'm
doing something so that i can offer that
person
um
the best not only of my clinical
knowledge but the best of a human
connection
that i can offer
so much of
the
destruction of substance use is the
isolation and the absence of connection
wow so i'm hoping that in a treatment
space they can at least feel that
there's a connection yeah
and that that's so insightful
on so many levels just the way that
you're able to step into that space
and and it sounds like a um
a giving back
because you know what you've been given
as you talked about from that spiritual
connection knowing god's presence with
you and how much
more you can be a conduit
to try and be that for others i think is
now i'm just uh imagining that those
that you work with can definitely sense
that
in your presence as well and how
far that can go especially with all the
challenges that you just mentioned too i
mean just to have a space where people
can be willing to as we talked about
share their story
without fear of judgment and know that
someone's there
walking through that story with them
even though you might not be in it per
se but that you're there with them and
how impactful that must be
in people's lives so
well definitely appreciate the way you
say that and i anticipate that i would
think that people who are listening can
sense that in you as well and they also
give them
just strength and courage to try and do
that for others as hard as it can be but
even the way that you frame that i think
is very
real and very honest and you also gave
yourself grace in that too because it's
not gonna happen perfectly each time but
as much as you're
striving through that and i would add
that god is helping you do that as well
i think is
is huge
wow
such an inspiration
in so many ways so i definitely
appreciate
just all that you continue to do um and
then your perspectives i feel like
there's there's more to come even as i
know you continue to step into new roles
and to have different levels of of
impact uh for me hearing that that's
very exciting just knowing your heart
and the ways that you're
touching lives and investing in lives i
can only imagine that those things will
continue to move
things forward for us as a society even
as it has ripple effects where you are
in your clinical setting but how that
can also impact
other places as well and also what you
do on the national level with different
organizations so
thank you very much you're in the right
place
oh thank you that is that is very kind
and um
very much appreciated
yeah of course
well thank you so much for joining i
hope that our listeners have sensed
everything that i've sensed as well just
in terms of your investment your wisdom
your excellence um i think i think just
the field and your community is just
fortunate to have you in this role and
we're fortunate to be able to benefit
from that today on the addie hour and i
i can't help it but the addie hour
listeners you've benefited from dr
mathis in ways that you don't even know
as she has invested in this work and
helped to set the foundation so this has
really been
just an encouraging conversation
it's always good to talk with you and to
hear uh what you're up to what god is
doing in your life and the ways that
you're just having impact across the
board so thank you so much for joining
us thank you so much for having me it's
really been a pleasure um it's nice to
have a moment to like remember the joy
yeah that of just instead of just
running from one to the other it's nice
to just have a moment to remember the
joy so thank you for that today of
course of course
[Music]
you